um for you has there been a moment um
you know obviously you you're pretty
transparent about the loss of your
mom um you know for you talk about
like is there any advice you would give
to anybody who has to grieve and still
has to try to get through life when it
comes to getting through such a a
traumatic unexpected loss you know what
I mean considering the circumstances
people can do their research but is
there any advice or any cuz I mean
that's that's a rough thing to get
through and push yeah like in the fact
of the matter is it's going to be hard
getting through it you never you're
never really going to get through the
loss of your mom like you're never going
to just completely get through it I
never did and I'm still trying to get
it's always going to be there like that
hurt that feeling that emptiness that
loss but you just got to just keep going
and find a way to cope through it and
just like don't let it break you don't
let it make you go crazy don't make it
don't let it make you stop going cuz a
lot of [__] they lose somebody they
love and they lose their self they lose
their mind and you got to just like
really put up that fight to just be like
all I'm not going to lose myself like
that [__] going to hurt me and I'mma
grieve and it ain't going to 100% heal
ever but I got to keep going and some
people got kids some people got things
they want to do in their life like you
got to keep going if it's not for you
let it be for something else you know
what I mean 100% yeah I had a friend of
mine recently who lost his kid
unexpectedly in a car accident and I was
just like dude I don't even know [__]
go crazy if I lost my son I don't even
know what I do I probably I just feel
like I would just disappear somewhere I
don't know that's why like that's why I
just keep the people I love feel me and
I just be like you know what's another
good thing though like being voices for
other people mhm you know like other
people that's going through the same
thing like being you're kind of like the
voice of the voiceless a thank you yeah
yeah um who who do you listen to right
now not not like your alltime greats but
like who's just like some music if if we
were to open up your Spotify or apple
music like what did you do your your
recap like your personal recap like who
were your top five I don't even stream
music I I listen to music on YouTube I
don't stream music that's the crazy part
yeah a lot of people are like that like
I don't know why YouTube doesn't do a
recap yeah I don't stream music on on um
those things but I do stream music on
YouTube so what you listening to I
listen to um of course my playlist is
like Drake doat cardi
B ice Bice I listen to a lot of Billy
ish Billy ish shout out to her yeah
that's my I love her Billy eish is fire
yeah I just be listening to music on um
on YouTube and stuff YouTube and stuff
you know who I like right now that's hot
in New York this guy um he um bro hold
on let me talk bro moving stiff when he
walk I think it's j hound and J5 that
sounds like what you just did right now
sounds like so many New York rappers oh
hold on Yo am I crazy you can can you
give me some insight
here I feel like there's so many rappers
who just sound like pop smoke now not
like the way they rap or what their but
their voice MH it's like they're so like
like we went to New York we hung out
with Dusty l k he sounds like popm smoke
and he knows this he's homie free Dusty
Lane uh what was the other guy Ross
swish sounds like pop smoke so it's like
is this like something in the water
where everyone's got a [__] deep
raspy voice it's crazy you know what I
think it's just because Us New Yorkers
we talk away so it's like if you hear
somebody
from Chicago or something and you'll be
like oh they all rap the same or
something like that it's not that they
all I'm not I'm not saying that I'm
talking about their voice their voice
their talking voice I mean I don't know
maybe it's
it's like it's crazy bro it's like now
shout out to them though because they
really be putting the city on uh you got
a lot of big homies in the rap game we
already talked about Buster rymes uh any
other uh guys who have you know
obviously embraced you and given you
some some
game um yeah there's a lot of people
like I don't I got a 50
Cent shout out to 50 Cent what 50 tell
you they teach you how to be Petty
pettiest [__] alive right there
I love it I just study his the way he
like he's just a genius you feel me oh
he is I think he's going to buy Revolt
from Diddy by the way that's my
prediction it's going to happen I just
feel like one day we're going to wake up
and Diddy's GNA own or Diddy's going to
sell Revolt to 50 I don't know we'll see
I just think he's that kind of petty but
you know anybody else besides 50 oh yeah
I performed that rote before shout out
to that that was a fun experience
hopefully not too fun and them people in
Atlanta they was [__] with me too I
was like back the [__] up move the [__]
back he